y medidas para combatir la escasez y la
inflación en el campo egipcio esto es lo
que están haciendo los agricultores de
la ciudad de 'la ya está para hacer
frente al acuciante crisis de alimentos
que afecta a uno de sus bienes básicos
más preciados el trigo
de cultivo trigo solo para uso personal
si me sobra se lo doy a mis vecinos sólo
vengo pero principalmente cultivo trigo
para niños o personal porque este año
teníamos una escasez
egipto principal importador mundial de
este grano trae el 80 por ciento de
trigo proveniente de rusia y ucrania un
escenario ahora alterado por el
conflicto bélico entre ambas naciones es
por ello que el presidente abdel fatah
al sisi hizo un llamado a la producción
local de este insumo agrícola que este
año podría alcanzar cosecha récord
cultivamos todos los años pero este año
hemos plantado más para no tener que
importar trigo de ningún otro país
según los datos de organizaciones de
consumo cada egipcio consume 180 kilos
de trigo al año cuando la media mundial
es de 80 kilos ahora además de la guerra
en ucrania y una inflación disparada la
sequía que atraviesa el país del noreste
africano también dificulta los
agricultores que ven como la suma de
estas causas ha disparado los precios de
las cosechas
en cuanto a los precios del trigo nos
estamos viendo afectados debido a la
crisis de ucrania los precios se
duplicaron y ahora tenemos problemas
para producir pan los precios del trigo
el maíz aumentaron todo subió de precio
media
mientras los más de 100 millones de
egipcios viven hoy a las puertas de una
nueva crisis económica el gobierno
intenta llegar a un acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional e intenta así
dar una salida a esta emergencia